neuf français sur dix ont envie de
changer de job
c'est ce qu'a révélé une étude de
nouvelle vie pro
statistiquement parlant ça veut dire que
dans cette salle vous êtes au moins 90
avoir cette envie de changement
et selon ces mêmes statistiques à peine
la moitié d'entre vous auraient commencé
une démarche de changement
imaginez un monde où tout le monde se
lèverait le matin excité à l'idée
d'aller travailler
pour ma part je suis persuadé que ce
monde serait meilleur
je m'appelle alexandre aride où je suis
coach certifié et j'accompagne justement
les salariés non épanouis dans leur
poste à trouver et atteindre ce job qui
les fera vibrer
et d'ici quelques minutes vous saurez
pourquoi 55% des personnes qui veulent
changer de job ne le font pas et surtout
je vous donnerai l'une des clés pour
rendre ce que vous pensez impossible
possible
mais avant de vous donner tous là
j'aimerais un peu vous raconter mon
histoire
je n'ai pas toujours été passionnée par
mon job non d'ailleurs quand je
réfléchis
j'étais plutôt le profil pas de passion
particulière
et comme j'avais pas de passion
particulière et que ce n'était pas
mauvais en maths
j'ai fait des études d'ingénieur
c'est comme ça que j'intégrais lutte
était
pendant mes études
comme tout bon étudiant qui se respecte
j'ai utilisé mon temps libre pour faire
la fête
j'ai beaucoup fait la fête bon ok
peut-être un peu trop mais c'est pas ça
dont je vais vous parler pendant mon
temps libre j'ai également dévorer de
nombreux livres de développement
personnel
j'étais fasciné par ces coach en
développement personnel
on a tous des personnes qu'on admire
réfléchissez un peu à ces personnes que
vous admirez ça peut être le musk bill
gates michelle obama
rafael nadal
greta
peut-être même des personnes de votre
entourage
pour ma part j'admire lé coach en
développement personnel pour moi il
avait le job de rêve un job tourner
autour de l'humain
mais bon comme vous sûrement avec ces
personnes que vous admirez je me disais
clairement alexandra tu ne pourras
jamais avoir leur vie non 2 1 je pense
être clairement pas avoir cette capacité
à inspirer les gens et de deux je vais
pas me voiler la face on n'a jamais vu
un roi du développement personnel faire
des études d'ingénieur
clairement cette idée c'était à mettre
au fond de ma tête
alors je me suis concentré sur ce que je
pouvais faire avec mon diplôme
d'ingénieur et c'est comme ça qu'à 24
ans je suis rentré dans le monde
professionnel par la porte de la
logistique
j'ai intégré un grand groupe
agroalimentaire est globalement mon rôle
c'était de me battre pour éviter des
ruptures en magasin
qu'est-ce que j'étais fier dans les
débuts de dire que si vous consommiez
des produits c'était un peu grâce à moi
et ouais c'est mois de calme a
provisionné vos produits
d'ailleurs à cette époque là je vais
être honnête avec vous mieux valait ne
pas m'inviter à l'apéro parce que si
vous invitiez et vous aviez acheté des
verres que concurrentes
vous allez vous faire la gueule toute la
soirée
puis les années passent et j'ai 29 ans
j'ai gravi quelques échelons je suis
devenu manager
qu'est ce que j'ai adoré manager
qu'est ce que j'ai adoré ça va grandir
mon équipe
par contre la logistique
comment vous dire
la logistique en fait ça n'avait plus
aucun sens pour moi non dans un monde de
surconsommation tu le voyais plus du
tout l'intérêt de me battre pour éviter
des ruptures
puisque le monde en avait vraiment
besoin
d'ailleurs bonne nouvelle maintenant
vous pouviez désormais m'inviter à
l'apéro j'en avais plus rien à faire que
vous achetiez départ concurrentes
mais bon chaque jour je continue de me
battre pour éviter des ruptures
et chaque soir j'avais cette petite voix
vous savez les titres en interne on n'a
pas trop envie d'écouter ben moi cette
petite voix elle me disait mme alexandra
mais qui est l'énergie gaspillée tu
pourrais pas faire quelque chose qu
aurait un réel impact sur la vie des
gens
bah ouais mais mais quoi il ya bien un
coaching qui t'attire mais voyons c'est
trop jeune papa fait les études pour les
ans plus tard que tu connais pas grand
chose du monde professionnel c'est quoi
cette idée
allez on referme cette idée et on
reprend le rythme métro boulot dodo
et puis un jour
je lis un livre de tony robbins un grand
coach en développement personnel et là
le déclic là je découvre le concept des
croyances limitantes est ce que vous
savez ce qu'est une croyances limitantes
une croyances limitantes c'est quelque
chose que vous allez juger vrai mais qui
vous tirent vers le bas et qui
finalement
n'est peut-être pas si vrai que cela
si je reprends ma croyez moi mais on est
gamin exemple j'avais là croyances
limitantes que ce n'était pas légitime à
devenir coach
comme j'avais cette croyance je faisais
rien pour essayer de devenir coach ceux
qui venaient donc renforcer le fait que
clairement alexandra t'es pas fait pour
être coach
ce concept autour des croyances on
appelle cela la boucle auto validante
laissez moi vous expliquer
partant d'une de vos croyances
vous allez avoir un comportement
qui va engendrer un résultat
qui va venir confirmer votre croyance
et vous savez quoi
c'est à cause de ce cercle vicieux là
que 55% des personnes qui ont envie de
changer de job ne le font pas
alors réfléchissez un peu maintenant à
toutes ces croyances qui vous empêchent
d'avancer
ça peut être comme moi des croyances
autour de la légitimité
mais ça peut être des croyances autour
de la peur financière la peur de l'échec
la peur du regard des autres
vous savez quoi
j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour vous il est
possible de retourner vos croyances il
est possible finalement de rendre ce que
vous pensez impossible aujourd'hui
possible c'est ce que j'ai découverte
dans ce livre de tonio vite et je vais
vous donner tout de suite la clé
pour cela il faut que cette fois-ci vous
partiez du résultat que vous souhaitez
atteindre et que vous posiez la question
quel comportement
devez vous mettre en place pour
atteindre ce résultat
est en vous posant la question quel
comportement dois-je mettre en place
pour atteindre ce résultat
vous verrez que vous viendrez modifier
votre croyance
et rendre ce que vous pensiez impossible
possible
c'est tout ce que j'ai fait j'ai pris ma
croyance je ne suis pas légitime pour
être coach je me suis posé la question
quels résultats aimerais-tu atteindre
j'aimerais devenir coach maintenant ok
quel comportement doit tout mettre en
place
ah ça je ne sais pas
alors du coup j'ai fait comme vous
touche quand on sait pas
je suis allé voir sur google
je fais des recherches sur google et là
qu'est ce que j'ai découvert
qu'il y avait des couches de toute
expérience des causes de tous profils de
tout âge et bonne nouvelle il y avait
même une multitude d'écoles de coaching
j'étais tout excité ça y est jamais
retourné ma croyance je me sentais enfin
légitime à devenir coach
du coup tout excité comme j'étais je me
suis dit alexandra va encore plus loin
va contacter des coachs pour connaître
leurs expériences à voir leur retour
j'avais donc repéré une dizaine de coach
et je comptais faire des appels
téléphoniques
qu'il première entretien téléphonique je
décroche tout excité oui bonjour
alexandre aride où je suis ravi de
pouvoir échanger avec vous j'aimerais en
savoir plus sur votre métier de coach
la personne me répond
oui bonjour
alors je préfère vous prévenir tout de
suite le métier de coach
on n'en vit pas moi si j'étais vous
changerait d'idée parce qu'alors
vraiment son approbation de coach on est
très peu en vivres et d'ailleurs moi je
fais ça que bénévolement donc j'ai un
conseil faites ça pour votre loisir mais
gardez en vrai métier à côté
waouh
moi qui avait réussi à retourner ma
croyance et qu'ils étaient super excitée
je crois que cette personne elle m'a
retournée comme une crêpe
mais bon je reprends mes esprits et je
me dis alexandra tu sais quoi cette dame
finalement c'est une croyance qu'elle a
va appeler d'autres coaches et j'appelle
donc comme ça une dizaine de gouache
bon mauvaise nouvelle pour moi les
résultats sont à peu près tous les mêmes
il est très difficile de vivre
financièrement parlant du coaching
d'ailleurs seulement 10% des coach
certifié en vivent
pour moi c'est un peu retour qu'à ce
départ je fais un point rapide sur ma
situation je suis en cdi je suis bien
payé je fais du bon boulot j'ai envie de
fonder une famille
clairement est ce que j'ai envie de
quitter tout ça et prendre autant de
risques pour un métier qui ne rapporte
pas argent
non clairement ce métier de coach il est
beaucoup trop risqué si je veux pas
vivre du coaching je préfère rester dans
ma vie
alors je reprends mon rythme métro
boulot dodo
et chaque soir j'ai cette petite voix
qui revient
d'alexandra mais [ __ ] quelle énergie
gaspillée tu pourrais pas mettre ton
énergie dans quelque chose qui aurait un
réel impact sur la vie des gens
on en a déjà parlé pour quoi faire il ya
que le coaching qui me vient à l'esprit
mais le coaching en a parlé c'est trop
risqué financièrement tu ne peux pas
bon comme savaient pas quoi faire
d'autre on reprend le rythme métro
boulot dodo
et puis un jour dans le métro parce que
tu entends ça a du bon le métro j'écoute
un podcast
et là je redécouvre la méthode des
petits pas
est ce que vous connaissez la méthode
des petits pas
la méthode des petits pas ça consiste
quand on a un objectif qui paraît trop
ambitieux à le diviser en soit objectif
puis ans ou étape puis ans ou petites
actions jusqu'à avoir des tout petits
pas pour que petit pas par petit pas on
atteigne notre objectif
alors oui cette méthode des petits pas
elle marche seulement si votre objectif
est ambitieux mais également réaliste
si vous avez 50 ans et vous souhaitez
devenir astronaute je connais pas votre
situation actuelle mais ça me paraît
quand même très très très compliqué dans
cette méthode elle marche si vous avez
un objectif ambitieux mais réaliste et
je peux vous garantir que si vous
utilisez la méthode du retournement des
croyances avec la méthode des petits pas
vous pouvez réellement rentrer que vous
pensez aujourd'hui impossible possible
et c'est donc ce que j'ai fait j'ai pris
ma nouvelle croyance je ne peux pas
vivre financièrement du coaching gelé
d'abord retourner au quai quels
résultats souhaités atteindre souhaité
pouvoir vivre du coaching ok quels
comportements devaient se mettre en
place
dans ces cas là il faut que j'arrive à
assurer financièrement ma transition et
ensuite avoir des clients réguliers pour
pouvoir en vivre
ok quel petit pas devait se mettre en
place
là encore je sèche mais je me suis
forcée je me suis forcée chaque semaine
à faire au moins un petit pas alors au
début c'étaient des recherches google
puis un jour je me suis retrouvé
inscrits à une formation de coaching tu
me suis retrouvé certifié coach puis
j'ai quitté mon cdi et
je suis devenu coach
moi alexandra l'ingénieur gérant dit
j'ai rendu possible serait ce qui me
paraissait impossible il ya quelques
années et je suis devenu coach
si vous avez vu la ferrari garée sur le
parking
je vais être honnête c'est pas la vienne
non je roule pas encore sur l'or mais
bon il faut subvenir à mes besoins et
surtout chaque matin je me lève excité à
l'idée d'aller travailler et ça je peux
vous garantir que ça n'a pas de prix et
en plus avec la méthode du retournement
des croyances et des petits pas je sais
que suis désormais capable d'atteindre
tous mes objectifs à venir
mais bon si on arrêtait un peu de pas et
de moi si on parlait de vous
quelle est cette situation idéale que
vous aimeriez atteindre
prenez quelques secondes pour l'imaginer
ou est-ce que vous voyez
qu'est ce que vous faites
avec qui êtes vous
comment vous vous sentez dans cette
situation idéale
et quelles actions avez-vous dû mettre
en place pour atteindre cet idéal
alors ce soir
je ne vais pas vous demander de lycée
toutes les raisons qui font que cette
situation est inatteignable
je ne vais pas non plus vous demander de
lycée toutes les raisons qui font que
votre vie c'est plus compliqué que ça et
que mon discours il est trop utopiste
non ce soir
je vous invite à vous poser les
questions
quels comportements devez vous mettre en
place pour atteindre cette situation
idéale
et quel petit pas pouvez-vous mettre en
place dès cette semaine
alors oui le changement ne se fera pas
du jour au lendemain ça pourrait bien
prendre des mois voire des années et si
c'était si simple
tout le monde travaille avec passion
aujourd'hui
non le chemin et être compliqué
mais si vous vous mettez pas dès
aujourd'hui à avancer vers cet idéal
qui vous dit que vous ferez un jour
alors pour finir ce soir je vous propose
que tous ensemble chacun d'entre nous
on retourne nos croyances
on avance petit pas par petit pas
et on rend ce qu'on pense impossible
possible pour un monde meilleur
merci